>>Brian: Hello everybody. Thank you so much
for coming and having a chat with Ben Dattner.
I am really happy and proud to introduce him.
Back in 1995, he and I were two of the four
incoming excited students at NYU's IO Psychology,
Industrial Organizational Psychology PhD program.
So we've known each other for a very long
time.
And I remember for as long as I've known Ben,
he's been interested in how we warp reality
to meet our needs. And I remember your dissertation
was actually on narcissists and whether narcissists
have a different perception of what they do
and whether it's perceived as fairer than
the people who report up into a narcissist.
So actually I wasn't surprised when I heard
about this book, which is "The Blame Game,"
all about how we assign credit and dole out
blame for the things that happen in the workplace.
So, very eager to hear what you have to say,
Ben. And welcome to Google.
>>Ben Dattner: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you very much. And for anybody who is
curious, Brian's dissertation was about nepotism
and we used to joke about what is the term?
Is it a nepot for a man and a nepata for a
woman? We never actually came to a consensus.
So thank you for coming. I'm very happy to
be here. I credit Google for my ability to
write this book, because my co-author and
I, Darren Dahl, used Google every day for
everything that we did when it came to the
book, whether it was hunting down an article,
whether it was hunting down research, whether
it was looking for famous people, whatever
it may be.
Famous stories, we used Google all the time.
And it is interesting in today's world, who
gets credit and blame for things. I'm sure
you're all thinking about news and news aggregation
and what's paid for and what's free, what's
linked to, what makes your profile higher,
or lower, on Google and what that means.
So we'll be thinking about that as we move
forward. So as Brian mentioned, I'm an organizational
psychologist, as is he. I'm very impressed
by the work that you guys are doing here when
it comes to people analytics. And luckily,
Google is an organization that already has
in mind the kinds of errors and biases people
make.
When it comes to assessing performance, there
was that great New York Times article a couple
weeks ago about people analytics at Google
and how you're given cues when you, for example,
fill out a performance appraisal form. Keep
in mind the recency effect, the primacy effect,
the halo effect. So this is an organization
that already has those things in mind.
So why credit and blame? Why did I write this
book? Well, as I work as an organizational
psychologist, I work with individuals and
teams in organizations large and small, for
profit and not-for-profit in the US and abroad.
And what I find is regardless of what I'm
doing, whether it's working with an individual,
doing conflict resolution between two individuals,
facilitating the work of a team, or facilitating
the work between teams, credit and blame is
where everybody's energy is.
Who's being credited? Who's being blamed?
Is it fair? Is it not fair? Is it accurate?
Is it not accurate? Is it helpful, or is it
not helpful? And in the work that I do, I'm
not able to be helpful to an individual pair
of people, team, or organization without challenging
notions of credit and blame-- the narratives
of credit and blame.
Who's getting the credit? Who's getting the
blame? Because of our hardwiring as a species,
because of each of our individual early-life
experiences, it's very rare that we credit
people for the same reasons at the same time
in the same way. Each of us comes to work
each day with the legacy of our own families,
our own culture, our own gender, and that
impacts how we credit and blame ourselves
and others.
And the book is really about how credit and
blame is not just an effect of organizational
behavior. It's actually a cause of organizational
behavior. So it's not that organizational
triumph or tragedy happens and then credit
and blame result. What the book does is it
flips it around and says, "What about the
patterns of credit and blame that set the
groundwork that lay the foundation, for success
or failure?"
Hence, the subtitle of the book, "How the
rules of credit and blame determine our success
or failure." So, the book starts out by looking
at why blame is so important. And it works
at every level of analysis. So, an individual
in his or her career is going to be thinking,
"How much credit do I deserve for my accomplishments
on a team?
How much blame do I deserve when things go
wrong?" And even starting there, people then
to take and claim more credit for themselves
in their own contributions and accomplishments
than others would give them. So if you ask
members of a team, for example, what proportion
of the team's accomplishments or results were
you personally responsible for?
If you ask ten people on the team, they'll
each say, "About 20 percent, 30 percent, 40
percent, 80 percent." Whatever it may be.
And if you add up those numbers, it'll add
up to far more than a hundred percent. It's
a little bit like the fictional shares in
the Broadway show in the movie of "The Producers,"
where they sell more shares than there actually
are.
And so, credit and blame--. Everybody, we
have self-serving biases. We have a lot more
information about what we've done and what
we've contributed than we do about what other
people have done and what they have contributed.
So part of it's an informational thing. We
have much more information about ourselves
and our hard work.
But part of it's also a bias thing and a motivational
thing, which is, we are motivated to overestimate
our own contributions and to underestimate
those of others. And these dynamics and these
self-serving biases soon cascade up within
relationships within and between teams, and
in entire organizational cultures.
So in the introduction to the book, I talk
about the proverbial six phases of a project.
Is anybody familiar with those? The six phases
are, and I don't know whether it's applicable
here or not, are enthusiasm, disillusionment,
panic, search for the guilty, punishment of
the innocent, and then rewards for those who
had nothing to do with it.
And so, even though we studied many formal
academic models of credit and blame over the
course of our academic and professional careers,
it's rare in my experience that a project
doesn't at least have some of those attributes
as it winds its way from conception to completion.
People care too much and they sub optimize.
If there's one lesson in people's careers
and the Center for Creative Leadership, where
I'm an affiliate, has done longitudinal research
about what makes people successful over the
course of their careers, it's tempting to
take credit in the short term, to overestimate
your contributions and your talents. But it's
actually quite harmful over the longer term.
And people who are unrepentant, unremitting,
self-creditors have a problem. First of all,
they're gonna be resented by their co-workers
and colleagues. But second of all, if they
take credit for everything, they're not going
to learn. They're not gonna take feedback.
They're going to have a fixed view of their
own capabilities, rather than to take a learning
approach.
And so, people, how you manage credit and
blame for yourself and others is a key determinant
of career success, regardless of the size
of your organization. And so, it's important
as you go through your career to think about,
"How am I taking credit and blame? Is it fair?
Is it accurate?" As I mentioned before, people
tend to sub optimize.
People fight too hard to get credit that they
think they deserve, but that other people
don't necessarily think they deserve. And
when we feel blamed, we tend to work too hard
to get exonerated of that blame. And like
many other things in life and work, the underlying
issue, the underlying contribution that you
did or didn't make, or mistake you did or
didn't make, is often much less important
than what you do about it afterwards.
So, if you're working on a project and you
feel under credited, that may or may not make
a difference. But if you fight so hard to
get the credit that you anger everybody around
you, you might end up--. They might say, "OK,
OK. It was you who did that, but now I don't
wanna work with you anymore. Now you're unpleasant
as a colleague and collaborator."
And similarly, you might push so hard to be
exonerated of a minor mistake or oversight--.
First of all, doing that might mean that you
have to then blame someone else. So one of
the lessons of this book is not to rush to
judgment, not to act impulsively, but instead
to think in a more mindful way about credit
and blame to make sure that you're acting
in a self-serving way, in a positive sense
of self-serving, not in a biased manner.
So, as the world changes and this is an organization
that's at the vanguard of those changes, the
world is much less about centralized bureaucracies
and centralized notions of credit and blame.
It's much more about networks and information
and less hierarchical and more horizontal
notions of information and linkages between
things.
One of the things I've heard about Google
is that in hiring people here, there's a resonance,
and there often is in the companies that I
consult to, that there's something about the
fundamental nature of the company that gets
enacted. It's almost like a work of literature
in which every little passage reflects the
whole.
What I've heard is that the hiring process
is a little bit analogous to doing a Google
search. People link to you. You're credible.
There's some secret algorithm, some secret
sauce, that determines whether you get hired
or not. And so in essence, that's a kind of
avant-garde world-changing, changing world
credit and blame, which is your Google rankings,
how you get hired, etc., is all part of the
new world of credit and blame.
So the first chapter is about evolution. And
even starting with our primate relatives,
I tell the story of Coco the Gorilla, who
lives in California. I don't know far from
your headquarters. But she learned several
thousand words of sign language and she's
monitored 24 hours a day. She's one of the
few characters in the book who is identified
by her real name.
I hope she doesn't mind. And so, one night,
Coco was playing with a toy cat and she accidentally
broke it. And the next morning, her morning
attendant came in and signed to her, "What
happened to the cat?" And Coco signed, "It
was my nighttime attendant who broke the cat."
So, even our gorilla relatives have a notion
of credit and blame and are able to literally
point the finger at someone else.
I also, from the evolutionary point of view,
tell the story of Capuchin monkeys. Brian
and I, when we were in grad school, had to
study equity theory, which was developed by
John Stacey Adams in the 60s, where he said
what workers do is they compare their inputs
with their outputs with their co-workers inputs
and outputs.
And it turns out that Capuchin monkeys do
the same thing. So, if you have a monkey pulling
a bar, and you're giving him a cucumber reward,
he will happily pull that bar and continue
participating in the experiment.
If you put another Capuchin monkey in an adjacent
cage where they can see each other but not
touch or directly interact, and if you give
that second monkey a grape for doing the same
task, the first monkey will become totally
indignant and enraged and actually go so far
as to throw the cucumber back at the researcher
because they have a notion of fairness.
And they say, "I'm pulling this lever. I'm
just getting cucumber. You're doing the same
thing. You're getting a grape." And so the
same is true in the workplace. We look at
our inputs and outputs and if our co-workers'
ratios of inputs to outputs are unfavorable
to us, we can act and react in an impulsive
primate-emotional hardwiring kind of way.
The interesting thing about this though is
that when you think of the four notions, the
four variables, in this equation, our inputs,
our outputs, your inputs, your outputs, all
four of those things are subjective.
What my inputs really are, what my outputs
really are. I mean outputs in terms of salary
and promotions or visibility might be concrete,
but each of us, because of our social wiring,
have many more subtle notions of outputs,
which is the esteem in which we're held by
colleagues, the likelihood that we may advance
in the organization.
And in that great Times article about Google,
you looked at what were the people analytics
team looked at what were the factors that
made people successful. And I don't know.
Did you look at credit and blame? Your next
assignment. Area for future research could
be how people handle credit and blame. I would
imagine though, the sort of emotional skills,
managerial skills, leadership skills, I would
imagine credit and blame is somewhere therein.
So any questions about the evolutionary perspective
on credit and blame?
[pause]
OK. So in Chapter One, I also talk about stereotyping,
which is, we have automatic preconscious notions
of credit and blame. And in the book, and
also in a Harvard Business Review article
that's out this month, I have a link to the
Implicit Associations Test, which is run through
Harvard where you can look at people from
different ethnicities, genders, races, backgrounds,
etc.
And the test assesses how quick are you to
make associations between positive words and
members of one group, and between negative
words and members of other groups. And what
the research shows is that no matter how enlightened
and equal opportunity we believe ourselves
to be, it still may be easier for us to make
an association between a Caucasian face and
a positive word and a member of an ethnic
minority and the negative words, simply because
of our socialization, our acculturation, because
of our exposure in the media.
And so, it's good to know the first step to
overcoming these things, which I think people
of good will wanna do, is judge people as
Martin Luther King said, "by the content of
their character and not the color of their
skin." Being aware of your biases so that
you can correct for those biases is something
that's very important.
And I know when it comes to Google and searching,
there's been stuff in the news recently about
search results--what qualifies as a good search
result, what's includable, what's not includable.
So that's an interesting credit and blame
that you all work with as well.
The book is about also, people shooting the
messenger that we tend to develop negative
associations and tend to scapegoat people
who threaten our world view, who threaten
organizational paradigms. And this has nothing
to do with people's merit, but instead has
to do with how they're perceived, how much
anxiety they bring up in the organization,
what have you.
And so, the book has some practical advice
about how to avoid being scapegoated, yourself.
And just like the other advice in the book,
it's about being mindful, making sure that
you're delivering your message no matter who
or what you're challenging, that you do it
in a mindful way, that you consider the timing
carefully, that you not embarrass anybody.
And if it turns out the emperor's wearing
no clothes, maybe you can send the emperor
an anonymous email, or something rather than
calling it out in a meeting.
[paper rustles]
The second chapter is about the nurture of
credit and blame. And what this is about,
is about how each of us, in the course of
our lives as we grow up in our families, we
learn about credit and blame from our families,
from our parents, from our siblings.
We learn what's praiseworthy. We learn what's
blameworthy. We learn about fairness. We learn
about unfairness. We learn about favoritism.
Sometimes in families, some kids can do no
wrong. They're the Golden Child. Sometimes,
no kids can do no right. They're the black
sheep of the family, if you will.
And so, this gets played out in the workplace.
So the book also talks about the notion of
transference, which is that we tend to reenact
family dynamics in the workplace. So, a boss
becomes a pseudo-parent and a co-worker becomes
a pseudo-sibling. Nepotism, if you will. So
it's nepotism not of the demographic, literal
sense, but of the psychological sense.
There's something that's known as homo-social
reproduction, which is that we tend to select
people and to affiliate with people who are
similar to ourselves, to reproduce ourselves
in that social manner. And not necessarily
people who are similar to us in a demographic
way, but people who are similar to us in terms
of other attributes that they have.
It could be in terms of values. It could be
in terms of education or other things like
that. And so learning about transference--I'm
not suggesting that everybody be on the couch
and do psychoanalysis for 15 years-- but still
reflecting on those things about how you're
caring about credit and blame, how your identity
is wrapped up in what you're doing for better
or for worse, can be very important.
And often, I find with my clients that in
order for them to understand what's happening
for them in their careers, it's very important
that they understand their buttons and which
buttons are being pushed. So I tell this story
in the book of a man of a financial services
executive who was assigned a coach because
Human Resources said this guy had no people
skills.
He has no managerial skills. And when I first
met with him, I inquired what had happened.
And he said that there was a merger. He never
really wanted to have a staff. As a result
of the merger, he was given several direct
reports, some of them in Europe. And there
was a woman who kept calling him and bothering
him, asking him questions.
And once, he got so fed up that he hung up
on her. He blamed her for annoying him, for
interrupting his work. And he hung up on her.
And in this particular financial services
organization, like in most other organizations,
at least is the way it should be, hanging
up on someone is not an acceptable way of
handling a workplace conflict, especially
when it's somebody who reports to you.
You're not setting a very good leadership
example. So, in our first coaching meeting,
I asked him--. You know, I'm not a psychoanalyst,
but I think it is important to understand
someone's story. How did they get to be who
they are? So I asked him, "Tell me about any
early life experiences that you think influenced
how you come across in the workplace."
And the first story he told, was he said,
"I grew up in an immigrant family. I was the
only kid out of five siblings who had any
academic talent or interest. I didn't have
my own room, so I would do my homework in
the dining room on a table. And my siblings
would always be ruckus and be annoying.
And then at the end of the day after they
were playing and I was finished with my homework,
my sister would come and demand that I help
her with her homework." And we were both like,
I mean, it didn't require my interpretation.
I was so immediately apparent to both of us
immediately that he was having a flashback.
That this direct report asking him that question
was just like being bothered by his younger
sister. So how he reacted, he blamed her unduly
because of this transference flashback reaction
he was having and in turn, got himself in
so much more trouble with the rest of the
organization because he was acting out in
an immediate, impulsive way.
So, knowing your own story, knowing what's
pushing your buttons, knowing your script
and making sure that you're not reenacting
that can be very important. I also talk in
the book about several other things. Michelle
Conlin wrote an article in Business Week 2004
called, "I'm a Bad Boss, Blame My Dad."
Dad, if you're watching, I don't blame you.
About how people act out in the workplace.
And it tells one story of an executive who
actually worked at Microsoft, who got in trouble
with his supervisors because he felt like
they were criticizing him. He had a flashback
to his parents criticizing him as a teenager
and it became quite problematic for him.
There's also in the book, a write-up of an
article in which some clients of mine appeared
in the New York Times in 2008. Three women
from an advertising agency called Tag Creative;
we're in the process of working with the three
of them and helping them with conflict resolution.
They each came to own that they were acting
with each other like sisters.
And they, two of them had sisters. One of
them didn't, but they were acting and reacting
to each other in a way that had nothing to
do with the moment at hand, but instead was
a flashback from earlier in life.
So, when it comes to credit and blame and
the emotions surrounding credit and blame,
knowing your story and to the extent you can,
trying to know without asking all kinds of
intrusive questions that violate laws about
people's early life experiences. Just trying
to get a sense of what their story is can
be quite helpful. Any questions about that,
about the nurture aspects of blame? Yes.
>>Male Audience Member # 1: [inaudible]
>>Ben Dattner: You mean like only, people
who are only children?
>>Male Audience Member # 1: Sure.
>>Ben Dattner: In my experience, only children
aren't different. And I mean there's always
exceptions to rules. And sometimes people
grew up with cousins and etc., etc. But on
my website, on datner consulting dot com,
there's actually a link to a Power Point presentation
that I did about birth order with leaders.
And there are some very well-known leaders.
For example, Jack Welch from GE, who were
only children. They tend to be very academically
successful, very comfortable with authority
and control. They may have a tougher time
working on a team. So all of these things
depend on a lot of different factors, but
there are somewhat consistent patterns.
And it may be--. Sometimes I've had clients
who were only children who were working on
teams and then they blame--. They don't blame
themselves, or they don't blame their parents
for not having more kids, but they say, "I'm
an only child so I find this sort of collaborative,
depending on other people and being so interdependent
on them, I find it particularly hard."
That's one of the things in the book, also,
which is that knowing yourself should never
be used as a rationalization. It should never,
"Of course I'm having a hard time collaborating
on the team. I'm an only child." Instead,
it should be, "I might have a harder time
because I'm an only child, but how do I then
work around that?"
OK. So the next chapter is called, "Typecasting
Blame." And what that's about is it's about
personality, both normal and dysfunctional
and how that relates to credit and blame.
On the book's website, which is credit and
blame dot com, there's a link to the Harvard
Business Review article, which is in this
month's Harvard Business Review, the April
2011 "Failure" issue.
In there, there's a link to a free test, the
IPIP 120. You can Google it. Which is a free
Big Five personality test, which will, for
free, give you a report. You answer 120 questions
and it will tell you where you fall on the
Big Five dimensions, which are--.
>>Brian: Conscientiousness, Agreeableness,
Extroversion, Openness to Experience-- did
I say that one? Neuroticism.
>>Ben Dattner: CANOE. Kudos to Brian for remembering
stuff from grad school. So, depending on where
you fall on Conscientiousness, Agreeableness,
Neuroticism, Openness to Experience, and Extroversion,
there are those dimensions and then there
are also sub factors.
So for example, one of the sub factors of
Conscientiousness is achievement striving.
If you're high on achievement striving, you're
gonna care a lot about getting credit for
things and wanna make breakthrough contributions.
One of the sub factors of Neuroticism is anger.
You can be angry. You can have anger within
you that comes out in the workplace.
And if you're high on the anger sub factor
of Neuroticism, you might get extremely disproportionately
angry if you feel unduly blamed or insufficiently
credited. So the next part of that chapter
is about the dysfunctional personality types.
The OCEAN or CANOE Big Five is about normal
personality, but it's also important to keep
in mind that you might be displaying some
of the attributes of dysfunctional personality
types. And these dysfunctional personality
types fall into three broad categories. They're
extra punitive, where you blame other people
too harshly.
Impunitive, where you either deny blame, or
you deny your own role in the blame. Or, intrapunitive,
where you blame yourself too much. And each
one of these can be problematic. Men tend
to be more extra punitive or impunitive and
women tend to be more intrapunitive.
And there's a variety of sociological and
cultural reasons that that's the case, but
women tend to have a harder time taking credit.
They tend to underestimate how much credit
they're getting from other people. And men,
if they're displaying these dysfunctional
personality types, tend to be more blaming
of others.
So, when it comes to these categories, extra
punitive, there's the excitable, volatile
guardian and all these are listed in the book
as well as in the Harvard Business Review
article. So a volatile guardian overreacts
to minor mistakes, determines failure prematurely,
assigns blame unfairly, and reacts defensively
to feedback.
So if somebody is extra punitive, they can
be very hard to work with. They can be very
hard to work for. And although this might
protect their self-esteem and give them righteous
anger and righteous rage instead of self-criticizing
depression, they can be--, have a really hard
time learning over time. Impunitive, which
is denying blame, the big person on campus,
is someone who is good to steer clear of.
This is someone who becomes angry or hurt
when blamed, who will ingratiate with superiors
and distort information in order to avoid
blame. So, as I was walking here this morning,
I thought about Google's slogan, which is,
"Don't be evil." So part of it is "don't be
evil" when it comes to credit and blame. But
I think no less important, it's also "don't
assume evils."
Don't look for evil where there may not be
evil in your co-workers. Or, don't look for
failure. Don't look for under-performance.
One of the consistent themes in the book is
about how helpful it is to give people the
benefit of the doubt. That if you look for
blame, if you look for failure, you're more
likely to find it.
If you look for success, if you look for credit,
you're more likely to find that. So it's self-fulfilling,
for better or for worse.
Intrapunitive. So, a martyr would be an example
of somebody who had a dysfunctional approach
to the workplace.
his is someone who might accept more blame
than she deserves in order to preserve working
relationships, or to blame herself so harshly
that it deflects other people's criticism.
So what can you do about this? On the book's
website, on credit and blame dot com, there's
an assessment that you can take that I developed
and market in partnership with Performance
Programs.
And you can see how you fall on these eleven
different dysfunctional types, whether you're
likely to be perceived as displaying these
types. And if you are, if you are working
with a mentor or an executive coach, or even
with a trusted colleague or peer, you can
say, "How am I coming across? Am I handling
credit and blame?
Am I reacting to it in a good way? Am I assigning
it in a good way? As I progress in my career,
how can I do a better job of managing the
delicate balance for myself and for others
of credit and blame?" Any questions about
that before I move on to the next chapter?
OK.
So the next one is situational awareness,
which is there's the people and there's the
situation.
And in grad school, we suffered through many
conversations, discussions, and debates about
is it the person, is it the situation, or
is it both? And so, when it comes to workplace
relationships, when it comes to teams, there's
a lot of social influences that determine
how we assign credit and blame, how we react
to credit and blame.
And the analogy that I use in the book is
it's a little bit like water. Water can change
phase depending on the ambient environment.
So, water can be ice. Water can be water.
Or, water can be steam. And the same is true
of people and their personalities, which is,
we can be the equivalent of water, steam,
and ice.
And so, some people may not be extra punitive
until they're under a certain kind of stress
and then they can act out. Or, people may
not be intrapunitive under normal circumstances,
but then if things go wrong, if they're blamed
by other people, it can push buttons. It can
bring up early memories or what have you.
So, if you're trying to figure yourself out,
if you're trying to figure others out, there's
something known as the Fundamental Attribution
Error in organizational psychology and psychology
more broadly, where we over attribute to people's
character or their certain dispositions and
we underestimate the importance of the situation.
But when it comes to credit and blame, it's
important to not only think about someone's
traits, but also to think about their states.
What kind of state are they in? If they're
under a certain kind of stress, they may act
out and react in a dysfunctional way.
We may conclude that's just the kind of person
they are, but what all kinds of research and
organizational psychology shows is that situations
in the workplace can be powerful. Situations
can attenuate differences between people.
So, even though I might be extroverted, you
may be introverted. If we're both working
in sales, we both have to be extroverted if
we're going to be successful.
And similarly, just like situations can make
different people act the same, it can make
the same people act different. I might be
one way in one situation and another way in
another situation. So it's important in the
workplace to think about these influences
and to think about what kind of environment
are you gonna be most comfortable and successful
in, and where are you likely to face challenges.
Organizational Cultures. This is Chapter Five.
That's another kind of situational, contextual
influence on how we act and react in terms
of credit and blame. And some cultures are
open and people are willing to question their
own role in credit and blame, to think about
the contextual factors, etc.
Unfortunately, too many organizations have
scapegoats, search for the guilty, punishment
of the innocent, as I mentioned before. So,
what great leaders do, which is the next chapter,
regardless of where they are in their careers
or what level they are at an organizational
level, is they think about credit and blame
and how do you set a positive example rather
than a negative example.
There's a seminal article from the 70s. Steven
Kerr, "On the folly of rewarding A, while
hoping for B." And what great organizational
cultures do is they think, "What are we implicitly
or explicitly crediting or blaming? And are
we crediting or blaming the right thing at
the right time?"
I have clients who have said, "We wanna sell
higher margin products and all the sales people
say we're still compensated based on volume."
And so, if an organizational culture doesn't
recognize that it's sending mixed messages
and rewarding the wrong things, it's unlikely
that it's going to change.
So Chapter Six is about leaders.
Great leaders at different levels of organizations
and what they do. So, one example I tell in
the story is of Wernher von Braun, during
the 1960s. Even though he was controversial
in his role in the Nazi Rocket Program, he
was still a widely admired leader of the US-based
program. And one day, there was a rocket that
blew up at launch.
And an engineer came into von Braun's office
and sheepishly admitted that he had touched
a circuit board right before launch and that's
why the rocket had blown up. The engineer
came into work the next day expecting to find
a pink slip on his desk, but instead, there
was a bottle of Champagne from von Braun,
himself, with a note that said, "Thank you
for confessing your error. You saved us months
of diagnostic work and we may have never even
found out what had gone wrong with the rocket."
So that's what great leaders do. Amy Edmonson
at Harvard has said that "what great leaders
do is they create an environment that's safe,
where people feel safe in admitting mistakes
and being self-critical." But not necessarily
comfortable. Not an environment where everybody
feels so at ease that they don't worry about
making mistakes.
They still are committed--. They still feel
bad about making mistakes. But paradoxically,
leaders who encourage blame, who encourage
people to share blame, create better environments.
In the Organizational Culture chapter, I also
talk about Amy Edmonson's work about hospitals
where she found--this is another counter-intuitive,
paradoxical result-- that it's actually better
to go to a hospital, certain hospitals at
least, with higher error rates, rather than
lower error rates.
Higher surgical mistakes, higher drug administration
errors. And you might say, "Why would I want
to go to a hospital with a higher error rate?"
The reason is because those hospitals are
better on every other metric other than these
error rates. And the reason is because they
actually confess their errors. And because
they confess them, they are able to fix them.
In the comparison hospitals where they didn't
admit their mistakes, where they had lower
error rates, the errors were happening. They
were probably even happening at a higher rate
than the hospitals that reported the high
error rates, but people didn't actually convey
them or admit them. And therefore, the underlying
things couldn't be fixed.
Any questions? So what great leaders do, Michael
Dell is an example of this, is they are open
to feedback. Jim Collins, who wrote "Good
to Great," said, "What great leaders do is
they look in the mirror when things go wrong
to take responsibility and out the window
when things go right." And so, what great
leaders do is they accept feedback.
They take on blame. They take a customer-focus,
continuous, and improvement view. And when
they do that, they set an example for people
in the rest of the organization, to also take
blame and do not deny blame. To some extent,
what this whole book is about is it's really
about evolution.
It's about individual, team, and organizational
evolution. So, credit and blame are just a
proxy for pride, sight, shame, and all these
other things that can either, if you manage
them correctly, help propel you forward in
your career.
Or, if you're stuck because you're too much
about pride and too ashamed to admit mistakes,
or you're too afraid of the shame or embarrassment
of making a mistake to never experiment with
something new, if you don't risk failure,
it's unlikely that you'll be able to make
breakthrough contributions, or to make progress
over the course of your career.
Questions about that before I move on to the
final chapter? OK. So there are two parts
to the final chapter, which is about practical
approaches for yourself, as an individual
in your career, and also as the leader of
others in an organization. So the first one
is, take a step back. Don't act impulsively.
I talk about this in the book and also in
the Harvard Business Review article, which
is you can't always make things better when
it comes to credit and blame if you've been
insufficiently credited or unduly blamed,
but you can always make things worse. Each
of us has the capability to make things worse
by acting out in a rigid way, by blaming other
people, by denying it, by being a prima donna,
by being a drama queen, by doing whatever
it is that you do.
Acting out in a self-destructive, impulsive
way, I guarantee you everybody here has the
power to make things worse. Being strategic
is also important. Think about, "What is this
really worth to me? Am I winning the battle,
but losing the war?" And think about credit
and blame, how you're managing it.
And it's never a good idea to blame people
too much, but it can be a good idea to share
a little bit more credit than you believe
others deserve, because it's like the perceptual
thing where you have two lines. Those famous
perception studies, and one of them looks
longer just because of the context and perspective.
One of them looks shorter. Same is true when
it comes to credit and blame, which is, we
perceive that we deserve more credit. We perceive
that others deserve less credit. So it's good
to correct for those errors and biases. Understand
your own story.
So again, you don't have to do 15 years of
psychoanalysis, but knowing your story and
what motivates you, and what's your identity
and how is that related to work and how you
come across and how you're credited and blamed.
And how does that propel your success, but
also, how does that hold you back? So what
is your story and what are other people's
stories?
And how do you intervene? How do you make
changes and tweaks on an ongoing basis to
change that story? Know your type and your
risk factors. So, even if you take the credit
and blame type assessment and it tells you
you're a big person on campus, or you're a
martyr, you may still question it. You might
not fully come to terms with it and that's
OK.
But you might be perceived that way. So forget
about, for the moment, the reality of whether
you actually are or aren't, but if you're
coming across as taking too much credit, how
can you come across in a more modest, more
collaborative way? Fight the fundamental attribution
errors. So, try to look at the context.
And Google and Brian and his people help you
do that by saying, "Keep the context in mind.
There were contextual factors that make things
easier or harder for this person." And make
sure you're keeping in mind biases, the recency
effect, the primacy effect, etc. Start with
positive expectations. So again, as I mentioned
before, giving people the benefit of the doubt,
looking for credit rather than blame, will
be self-fulfilling. Any questions about those?
Please.
>>Female Audience Member #2: What's the most
common thing [ inaudible ]
>>Ben Dattner: The research actually did not
look at that. What we found was that 70 percent
of the population falls into one of those
dysfunctional types, but I didn't actually
see the statistics about which one was more
common.
That would be a good question for Robert Hogan,
for Hogan Assessment Systems. OK, so practical
approaches for leaders. Be a blame-savvy boss.
So, think about credit and blame, the dynamics
of credit and blame on your team. And be mindful
of how you're assigning it, how other people
are assigning it. Take an open and adaptive
approach rather than blaming people.
Think about how can we focus on solutions
rather than on problems, realizing that you're
setting an example with everything you do,
or don't do. Fight group think. So, try to
think about--. It's gonna be tempting for
people who report to you to become Yes Men
and Women and tell you everything you're doing
is great.
So, you have to keep in mind that sort of
social hierarchy and people's intimidation
and ask people questions like, "Well, if this
doesn't work, why wouldn't it work?" Or maybe
you assign people randomly to argue for or
against an initiative or a project that you're
considering just so there's a forum for that,
so people will feel, again, safe to speak
up even if they don't feel comfortable.
Focus on systems and situations. So think
about when you're talking with people about
their performance and what made it go well,
or didn't go well. What are the contextual
factors? And how can you, as a leader, get
them more resources or support or information
so that they can be more successful going
forward.
Get and keep the right people on the bus.
So when you're hiring people, try to ascertain
how do they do in terms of credit and blame.
Are they unduly crediting themselves? Are
they saying "I" when they really mean "we?"
Or maybe they're too modest and self-effacing
and they're saying "we" when they really mean
"I?"
But looking at people's pattern credit and
blame can be a great diagnostic as to whether
they'll be a good person to have reporting
to you or to have working with you. And the
last recommendation is to write a managerial
user's manual for your new team. And what
this is, is a document. It can be informal.
You can share it in writing or just verbally,
which is, "I'm your new boss. Here's what
you need to know about me. Here's what people
are likely to misunderstand about me." And
the reason this is relevant to credit and
blame is because people size each other up.
There can be cross-cultural miscommunications.
So, if I'm your new boss and I ask you a lot
of questions, you might panic and you might
assume that I don't trust you, that I'm trying
to get rid of you.
I'm asking a lot of questions and you might
get worried that this is really about me determining
who to fire. But if I say to you, "It's my
style to ask a lot of questions. It doesn't
mean that I don't trust you. It doesn't mean
that I'm trying to diagnose your capabilities.
I just ask a lot of questions." I have one
client who wrote a managerial user's manual.
She told her team, "I'm British, so I tend
to be reserved. And Americans tend to think
I'm standoffish and aloof. But I'm not. I'm
just British, so come talk to me anytime."
And there are other things like that where
people might say for example, "I like information,
even if it's unfinalized. So don't wait until
the last minute. Give me updates. I like updates.
Give me an update, even if the update is 'there's
no update.'"
And that way, there doesn't have to be tension
because you're not giving the manager what
he or she wants. So having this thing can
avoid misunderstandings and what I call in
the book, "mondegreens," which are when things
are misunderstood. And two famous stories
about that was Winston Churchill, during the
Second World War, was referring to a person
and he said to his staff, "Bring me Berlin."
Not the city, the person. So they bring this
man to his office and Winston Churchill says
to him, "So what's the latest thing you've
been working on?" And the guy says, "A song
called White Christmas." And in fact, Churchill
had wanted them to bring him Isaiah Berlin,
the great philosopher, but they brought him
Irving Berlin.
And there's another story about Herbert Hoover,
who had a rigid rule that there had to be
one-inch margins on every memo that was sent
to him. And some hapless FBI leader sent him
some note and where he proposed something,
but there was a lot of information so the
margins were thinner. And so Hoover said,
"Your plan is fine, but watch the borders."
And what he meant was watch the borders of
your memo, but instead, they panicked and
they sent FBI agents to the Rio Grande and
to Saskatchewan, or whatever, to watch the
borders because they thought he meant watch
the borders of the United States. So as a
leader, if people are intimidated by you,
if you're blaming, you paradoxically are less
likely to get what you want because people
aren't gonna approach you and ask for clarification.
They're gonna instead bring you the wrong
person and engage in the wrong task-based
behavior. And so, a user's manual breaks the
ice and makes sure that people feel comfortable
approaching you and that there aren't those
cascading misunderstandings of blame that
then will lead to poor results.
>>Male Audience Member #3: [ inaudible ]
>>Ben Dattner: Because there was a woman who
wrote a book where she heard this song about
Earl Murray and they laid him on the green,
but she misinterpreted that as Earl Murray
and they laid a mondegreen.
So she wrote this book, which is referenced
in the book, where she talked about mondegreens.
Like, excuse me while I kiss this guy, or
the girl with colitis goes by or things like
that.
>>Male Audience Member #4: And they said they
could build a reality show.
>>Ben Dattner: Yes. That would be great. Great,
so any questions or comments? Please.
>>Male Audience Member #5: [inaudible ]
>>Ben Dattner: So the question was, how does
the example of Coco the Gorilla and the Capuchin
monkeys relate to evolution? It could just
be a snapshot in time. Because I believe that
what the research has shown is that we are
hardwired for example, stereotyping. It's
something that was an evolutionary benefit
to determine is this person friend or foe?
So the Capuchin monkeys--. I also talk in
that chapter about bats, where there are vampire
bats that go out and suck the blood of large
mammals. And then they have this bat blood
co-op where they regurgitate blood into each
other's mouths. If one bat gets lucky one
night and gets prey and the other one doesn't,
they will actually regurgitate blood and share
with each other and then keep track of who
was stingy and who wasn't stingy.
So these bats have among the largest cerebral
cortexes in the mammalian world because of
these reciprocal things. So then you can say,
"OK, well these bats have these reciprocal
notions in a prototype of credit and blame.
So then, how does that relate to human evolution
and our big cortexes and our reciprocal keeping
track of social relationships."
So it's not to say that we evolved from bats
or even from Capuchin monkeys, but it's supposed
to say that we're not the only animals that
have notions of credit and blame and that
are able to point the finger, that care about
fairness, that track reciprocity, or that
are able to blame others. So this is something
that is likely.
It's always hard to verify any kind of evolutionary
psychology hypothesis because you can't really
do an experiment to test, "Let's have people
evolve without pointing fingers or what have
you." But it's argument by analogy. [pause
] Any questions from our YouTube viewers?
No? OK.
>>Male Presenter: Thank you, Ben.
>>Ben Dattner: Thank you very much.
[applause]
Good to be with you. I'll be here if anyone
wants a book signed.